OK, rolling...
Test, test, one, two..
My name is Anna Zayaruznaya
and I'm a music historian.
Music is the most ephemeral thing.
Music gets older faster
than anything else.
There's a guy Johannes Tinctoris,
who said in the 1460s
that music older than 40 years
isn't worth listening to. In the 1460s!
And if you think about the music your parents listened to,
maybe that's not your music.
Music is so tied to the moment
in which it's written
and first performed.
Given that, isn't it crazy we have music surviving from the Middle Ages?
I study music history
because it gives us a way
to get at aspects of the past
that I don't think are available to us
through any other means.
There's something about music
that is linked to the emotions,
that's linked to the body,
that's linked to the voices that sing it
or the instruments that play it.
There's something
so personal embodied about music.
If you hear that music then,
and it sounds so weird
for me that's the moment that's interesting, right,
is to then keep listening and say,
OK, well, I think that sounds weird.
But clearly they thought it was awesome.
So what kind of a subject would I need
to be to think that this is awesome
and what kinds of insights, then,
can I gain into
what it means to be human, what it means to be a listener?
Often music manuscripts
would get chopped up
and they would get used
to reinforce other bindings,
so you'd have a book from the 17th century
or something that would have
that would have as part of its binding material,
a piece of music from the 13th century.
And you have to figure out what's been
cut off in terms of words and notes and
piece it all together.
There are a couple of pieces of music
that I've reconstructed
from the 14th century
that once I was done with them,
we could sing them in ways
that we had never sung them before.
I think that's sort of what it
comes down to for me is to find
this music that feels foreboding
because it's in a different notation,
because it's in these sources
that are in these European archives
it's full of wormholes,
you know, it's decaying,
the pages are falling off.
It can be a mess.
And to restore it in some sense,
to turn it into something that can tell us
something about a person who lived once
and how they might
have experienced the world.
What is this music connected to?
Is it just a floating song?
No, the music is always for somebody,
from somebody, for some purpose.
So what was its purpose? That's one of the things we're doing.
But also it's a question
of what we can learn about ourselves.
I hope that my students come out of my classes
inspired to listen more carefully,
especially when they hear something
that they don't like.
I never ask anybody
to like the things we study.
I just ask them to sort of
attend to them carefully.
And I think the act of attending
carefully to something that sounds strange
is a life skill.